the coronavirus pandemic is affecting
all areas of the medical care system
and one area where it's becoming really
apparent is in organ transplants and
donations
from things like not being able to fly
organs on commercial or private
airplanes
or people not wanting to go into
hospitals because they're worried about
getting sick
so people aren't donating organs and
people are having to wait on weightless
for a lot longer
today i talked with dr david axelrod
about some of these
issues and what patients who are waiting
on weightless for organs should know
i think one of the most important things
to recognize is that
one of the major sources of organs
particularly for kidney transplant is
living donors and all of us have been
very concerned
that we don't put living donors at risk
by bringing them into the hospital
that of course means that the recipients
are going to wait for a longer period of
time so around the country about 90
of transplant from living donors have
stopped
and those that have continued have done
so sort of in
extreme circumstances if somebody is
waiting on a kidney transplant
and they've been waiting for a while how
long can they wait for are they in
immediate danger
if they can't get a transplant in the
next couple weeks or months
so the overall chance of dying on the
kidney waiting list is
about 1 in 20 per year for
folks who have type 1 diabetes it can be
as high as 1 in 5
per year um for relatively otherwise
healthy people may be less than that
so we sort of usually think about a six
to seven percent mortality per year
every year you wait so if we delay
transplants for three to four months you
expect maybe one to two percent of the
people to die
um on the waiting list and waiting for
those organs
uh unfortunately in this country it
really depends on where you live but we
have
waiting times in new york and in
california uh of seven eight nine years
so we already know that people are dying
on the waiting list and they're dying
every day
just back to basics for a minute um what
are some of the conditions that require
people to get an
organ transplant lung diseases can be
everything from
cystic fibrosis which is a disease that
we're born with
to copd and you know and bad diseases
where
it's acquired in the lifetime the most
common kind of transplant is still a
kidney transplant the major causes of
kidney trans
kidney disease that lead to failure are
still high blood pressure diabetes
and so what we see is that is the new
cause of end-stage liver disease that
we're gonna transplant
it's actually the obesity epidemic so
the obesity epidemic
obesity puts fat in the liver just like
alcohol and so
patients who are chronically obese for a
long period of time
develop cirrhosis in the same way when i
think of organ transplants one of the
things that pops into mind is that
stereotypical scene where
they're putting an organ in a cooler and
putting it on a plane and
flying it across the country how often
does that happen and
has the decrease in commercial flights
impacted that
you know i was talking to colleagues in
new york a couple weeks ago
they had a person who was on the list to
get a heart transplant had an organ form
had a patient for them and there was
literally no private planes
they could lay their hands on because
everybody was fleeing covey
for kidney transplants we routinely ship
them on commercial aircraft
and that's had a substantial uh
effect of the covid um you know as the
travel industry has contracted our
ability to transplant those organs
has been diminished because if we can't
get that organ here in a reasonable
period of time we obviously can't put it
in
uh we've been hoping to work around
those sorts of things there are ways of
preserving organs a bit longer and that
sort of stuff but it's highlighted
for the whole transplant community and a
need to
innovate the way we deliver those organs
you